Salut !
Est-ce que vous connaissez
le théorème du gruyère ?
Le paradoxe du fromage ?
- Non, celui-là, je l'ai pas.
- Plus tu as de gruyère,
plus tu as de trous.
Tu es d'accord avec ça ?
- Pour l'instant, ouais.
- Ouais, donc plus il y a de trous,
moins il y a de gruyère.
- Oui aussi, oui.
- Donc plus il y a de gruyère,
moins il y a de gruyère.
Salut !
Des figures impossibles
à réaliser dans le monde réel.
Des anamorphoses qui peuvent
être vues que selon un certain angle.
Des sculptures d'ombres qui
ne marchent que s'il y a telle lumière,
de telle manière, de telle façon.
Des phrases autoréférentes.
Bref ce genre de truc
qui rend ouf le cerveau.
Aujourd'hui, j'ai décidé de vous faire
découvrir des artistes incroyables,
des très vieux
et des très récents.
Qui ont tous un point commun :
Utiliser l'art et la perception du cerveau
pour nous rendre un peu dingues.
C'est au delà de l'illusion d'optique.
C'est de l'illusion artistique
qui fait un peu fumer les sens.
Même les sculptures
d'ailleurs impossibles,
vous allez voir qu'il y en a qui ont
réussi à rendre ça possible.
Loïc, générique.
D'après les recherches
qu'on a pu effectuer.
C'est-à-dire, quand je dis nous,
c'est parce qu'il y a Jérémy
qui a écrit cette vidéo,
quand même, il faut quand même
le préciser dès le départ.
Les premiers dessins de perspectives
impossibles auraient été fait, je crois,
par William Hogarth en 1754,
il avait 57 ans à l'époque.
Il a commencé à s'amuser de la
perception des perspectives sur un dessin.
C'est ainsi qu'il a réalisé cette gravure,
sur laquelle les événements qui ont lieu
sont clairement pas possibles.
Et pourtant, ça paraît normal.
Mais c'est pas possible.
Si vous regardez bien au premier plan,
on voit un homme qui pêche dans
de l'eau qui est située au deuxième plan.
Et au troisième plan,
on voit une femme qui interagit avec
un homme qui est situé sur la colline,
qui est elle-même
au quatrième plan.
La perspective des bâtiments
n'est pas logique non plus.
Il y en a un qui est vu d'en dessous,
alors que l'autre qui est plus grand
semble vu d'au dessus.
Et celui qui est encore
le plus brainfuck,
c'est le corbeau qui semble
tout à fait normal.
Mais si on y réfléchit,
il est beaucoup trop grand.
ça, c'est la plus vieille source
qu'on ait pu trouver.
Hogarth semble être le premier,
qui s'amusait vraiment
dans l'art avec les perspectives.
J'ai chaud Lolo.
Mais dis moi, ces abdos.
C'est pas une perspective ça, Loïc ?
- C'est dommage, on les voit pas.
- Et merde.
Avant de passer
aux sculptures impossibles
et au triangle impossible
d'Oscar Reutersvärd.
ça va être comme les chercheurs ça.
Donc avant de passer
à Oscar Reutersvärd,
on va s'intéresser
un petit peu à Escher.
Rapidement parce que
c'est passionnant.
Mais pourquoi rapidement ?
Vous allez vite comprendre.
Maurits Cornelis Escher ou Escher.
Je sais pas, peut-être Escher.
ça fait stylé Escher.
- Un peu comme le chanteur.
- Usher.
On a entendu là ?
Est-ce qu'on a entendu
la musique d'Usher ?
- On a pas le droit.
- Pourquoi ?
- Bah tu connais.
- Eh moins de trois secondes.
Escher était un artiste
Néerlandais, né en 1898.
En 1919, il intègre une école
d'architecture aux Pays-Bas.
Il commence à faire des voyages
en Espagne, en Italie,
dans plein d'endroits
qui vont influencer son travail.
Sur ce qu'on connaît aujourd'hui de lui,
et surtout sur le plus marquant.
Il était rebelle, Escher.
Et très rapidement, il s'affranchit
du côté naturaliste de ses dessins
et de l'architecture traditionnelle.
Pour aller vers quelque chose
qui l'obsède, le sens de l'équilibre.
Ou l'enchevêtrement des perspectives
à l'intérieur même,
d'une même composition.
Et ça commence à donner
des trucs comme ça.
Des dessins qui retournent le cerveau.
Là vous voyez chute d'eau
qui présente une cascade
qui prend sa source au bas
de la chute d'eau elle-même.
C'est pas logique.
Ou encore Haut et Bas
qui présente un lieu
vu de deux points de vues différents,
mais dans le même dessin.
Je vais pas m'éterniser sur lui,
parce que sa vie est passionnante.
Donc si vous voulez en voir
et en savoir plus sur lui,
je vous recommande de lire
le prochain Curiouz,
parce qu'il y a un dossier entier qui lui
est consacré qui est assez fascinant.
Histoire de le dire,
parce que ça fait plaisir.
Mais le prochain Curiouz,
c'est le numéro 10.
ça veut dire que ça boucle la première
année de ce magazine de 52 pages,
que vous recevez directement
dans votre boîte aux lettres.
Donc voila, merci
d'avoir soutenu ce projet.
Est-ce qu'il y aura
une deuxième année ?
La réponse est oui, ça continue
pour une deuxième saison de Curiouz.
Et si vous connaissez pas,
si vous étiez pas abonné
ou si vous voulez lire
le dossier sur Escher.
Vous avez le lien directement
dans la description.
Passons maintenant
à celui qui est considéré
comme le père
des figures impossibles.
Oscar Reutersvärd
qui est né à Stockholm en 1915.
C'est en 1934,
il a alors tout juste 18 ans.
Qu'il crée sa première
figure impossible.
Qui est une sorte de triangle
composé de cubes.
Après l'analyse de la figure,
notre expérience du monde,
des formes, des architectures
qui nous entourent,
ainsi que des lois de la physique.
Tout ça fait rapidement
dire à notre cerveau,
qu'il y a quelque chose
qui va pas dans cette figure.
Et que la logique
s'est barrée loin, loin, loin.
Mais pourtant
que ça a l'air plausible.
C'est tellement joli, qu'en 1982,
le gouvernement Suédois
décide d'utiliser ces formes là
pour faire leurs timbres poste.
Et aussi parce que
c'était l'année de ma naissance.
Du coup ils se sont dit, c'est cool.
- C'était aussi l'année de ma naissance.
- C'est faux, c'est pas possible.
Tu peux pas être né
à deux années différentes.
Le fait est que Reutersvärd s'est mis
à créer des figures si complexes,
que notre cerveau
fume littéralement quand il les voit.
Entre la compréhension
de la forme globale
et l'incompréhension de pourquoi
ça peut pas exister, cette histoire.
Ce qui est génial, c'est le moment
où les figures impossibles
commencent à créer
leur premier lien avec la science.
C'est ce qui s'est passé
grâce à Penrose.
Lionel Penrose,
c'était un généticien Britannique.
En 1958, il travaille
avec son fils Roger Penrose
et ils publient
toute une suite de géométries.
Mais surtout de figures impossibles
dans le Journal of Psychology.
On retrouve d'ailleurs dans ce journal,
dans cette édition là,
un triangle qui ressemble beaucoup
au triangle de Reutersvärd
qui a dû l'inspirer
d'une manière ou d'une autre.
Ce triangle est connu sous le nom
de triangle de Penrose, normal.
La famille Penrose est également
à l'origine de l'escalier infini,
que vous avez déjà vu.
Ou on l'appelle aussi
l'escalier de Penrose, qui avait en fait,
déjà été inventé plusieurs années
auparavant par Reutersvärd.
Et qui a été repris
quelques années plus tard par Escher.
Donc là vous voyez que tout
est connecté pour le coup,
un peu comme le triangle de départ.
Et l'escalier de Penrose ou l'escalier
de Reutersvärd ou d'Escher.
On sait plus à qui il appartient.
Il a été utilisé dans Inception,
dans le cinéma.
Le moment où ils sont dans le rêve,
c'est une manière de faire voir
que dans le rêve,
les architectures impossibles
deviennent possibles.
Avançons dans le temps et on passe
à un autre artiste de l'impossible.
Sandro Del Prete.
Il est né, lui, à Berne en Suisse.
Dans les années 60,
à l'âge de 23 ans environ,
il a commencé
à dessiner des scènes
qui pouvaient être regardées
de deux points de vue différents.
Vous les voyez actuellement,
ça s'apparente un peu plus à des illusions
d'optique qu'à des paradoxes.
Mais il en a tout de même
dessiné quelques-uns,
comme ce magnifique jeu d'échecs,
dans lequel les pièces font la guerre
pour conquérir littéralement
une partie ou l'autre de l'échiquier.
Ou encore ce dessin, sur lequel
une jeune femme cueille des pommes
grâce à un système
horizontal en bois.
Tout en passant par au-dessus
de la palissade verticale.
Celui-ci, je le trouve
un peu fou à regarder
parce que je me dis
à quel moment donné,
il a triché dans les traits
et il n'y a pas tant de triche en fait.
Aujourd'hui encore, il y a des artistes
qui explorent l'impossible.
C'est le cas d'Erik Johansson.
Je suis complètement fan
de son travail.
Et entre les recherches qu'on faisait
pour le nouveau Curiouz sur Escher
et ce que je connaissais
de Johansson.
Je me suis dit,
il faut qu'on en fasse une vidéo.
C'est un artiste Suédois,
il est né en 1985.
Il a commencé à créer du surréalisme,
au travers des photos
qui semblaient possibles.
Comme dans "Give me time",
par exemple.
On voit ce personnage
qui essaie de courir,
mais qui complètement retenu enchaîné
à deux énormes montres à gousset.
Mais il est allé plus loin
dans le paradoxal.
Celui-ci me rappelle un peu
dans l'idée de l'Escaliers de Penrose,
même si c'est pas le cas.
On voit l'homme qui doit
se rendre à une porte,
en passant par des escaliers,
qui semblent complètement
impossibles en réalité à atteindre.
Et c'est différent
de l'escalier de Penrose.
Parce que ici,
Johansson joue sur les ombres
pour faire passer
une surface horizontale d'un côté,
en surface verticale de l'autre.
Il a eu d'ailleurs l'occasion
de travailler pour des marques.
Il a d'ailleurs utilisé
le triangle de Penrose,
pour une marque qui s'appelle Aïshti,
je crois que ça se dit comme ça.
Il a recréé en Lego,
le fameux triangle de Penrose.
Et surtout, il a refait en photo
le fameux Haut et Bas d'Escher.
Mais à la base on se disait que
toutes ces représentations
n'étaient que possibles en dessin.
Ou en gravure.
Mais pas en représentation 3D
dans la vraie vie.
Et bien ça c'était avant que Francis Tabary
se mette à travailler là-dessus.
Francis Tabary, à la base,
c'est un illusionniste.
Il est né en 1949, il est très connu
dans le monde de la magie
puisqu'il a été champion
du monde en 1991.
Et quand il prend sa retraite en 2009,
il se met à essayer de réaliser dans
le monde réel, le triangle de Penrose.
Et d'autres figures comme ça, impossibles.
On n'a qu'une envie,
c'est d'y aller soi-même
et de faire le tour
pour voir à peu près,
comment c'est fait,
comment ça fonctionne.
Bref, c'est assez
impressionnant à voir.
Alors qu'est ce qui fait vraiment
fumer notre cerveau dans tout ça ?
C'est le paradoxe en tant que tel.
Et encore une fois,
c'est pas l'illusion d'optique.
C'est le côté paradoxal
de ça ne peut pas exister.
Et comment ça se fait qu'un mur
puisse avoir une surface
qui lui serve à deux surfaces
en même temps.
C'est ça qui rend fou.
Moi, ça me rappelle par exemple,
des choses pour le cerveau
qui sont complètement paradoxales.
Comme les phrases autoréférentes.
C'est-à-dire des phrases
qui font référence à elles-mêmes.
D'ailleurs si je dis :
Cette phrase n'est pas
une phrase autoréférente.
C'est un paradoxe.
Tu as compris Lolo ?
Tu vas mettre un jingle comme ça
à chaque phrase paradoxale ?
- Ouais.
- Okay.
Si je suis fier d'une chose,
c'est de ma modestie.
Sans transition,
je passe à la phrase suivante.
Avant de détruire définitivement
cette phrase, faites-en une copie.
Pour en savoir plus
sur les phrases autoréférentes,
si vous voulez en découvrir
un peu plus.
Je vous recommande
vivement l'ouvrage,
ou même les ouvrages
de Douglas Hofstadter.
Notamment "Gödel Escher Bach".
Ou encore "Le trésor des paradoxes",
qui est super bouquin
de Philippe Boulanger et Alain Cohen.
Beaucoup plus facile à dire ça.
Les sculptures en anamorphose.
Donc ce sont des œuvres
dont les formes sont distordues
et qu'on voit que d'un seul
endroit en particulier.
Et celle que vous êtes
en train de voir,
c'est celle de l'artiste
Français Georges Rousse
qui est né en 1947 à Paris.
Ces images sont vraiment
impressionnantes.
Et on imagine le travail de malade
qui se cache derrière.
Il explique quand même qu'aujourd'hui,
il est un petit peu déçu.
Parce qu'avant,
quand les gens voyaient ça,
ils trouvaient ça
complètement dingue.
Même quand il prenait des photos,
les gens qui voyaient
les photos faisaient :
"Oh mais c'est fou ce que tu as vu".
Alors qu'aujourd'hui, comme on est
habitué au travail informatique, etc.
Les gens pensent que tout le calcul
a été fait en amont par ordinateur.
Il y a un artiste Suisse qui s'appelle
Felice Varini qui est né en 1952,
mais qui vit à Paris.
Qui a eu la même idée.
Et on voit bien d'ailleurs,
que c'est pas tout à fait le même style.
Mais Georges Rousse et lui ont souvent
pour support de leurs œuvres
l'intérieur ou l'extérieur des bâtiments.
C'est un peu des sculpteurs qui partent
du vide pour créer l'anamorphose.
J'aime beaucoup.
Et il y en a qui vont plus loin.
C'est le cas de Mathieu Robert Ortis,
un artiste qui vient de Lyon.
Et qui nous éclate le cerveau
d'une autre manière.
Il fait des sculptures en anamorphose,
qui peuvent être regardées
sous deux angles différents
et donc qui représentent
deux choses différentes,
selon l'endroit où on la regarde.
Parce que là depuis tout à l'heure,
vous voyez un éléphant.
Mais de l'autre côté,
vous voyez deux girafes
qui se mordent chacune la queue.
Il semblerait que, peut-être,
Robert Ortis se serait inspiré
du travail de Markus Raetz
qui est un artiste Suisse également,
né en 1941, décédé début 2020.
Qui avait travaillé avec des miroirs
pour permettre de montrer
à la fois le recto et le verso
de ses œuvres en même temps.
Et Raetz avait été lui-même fasciné
par une question qu'avait posé Platon :
Une chaise est-elle la même chose,
si on la voit de face ou de côté ?
Parce que effectivement,
tous les objets ont des vues
de face, de profil, de haut.
Sauf la boule qui est la même vue
de n'importe quel point de vue.
Et encore c'est pas si sûr.
Mais quelqu'un qui n'a jamais vu
une chaise de profil pourrait se dire,
en voyant de ce point de vue,
qu'il s'agit d'un autre objet
que la chaise vue de face.
C'est notamment ce que Raetz
apporte dans ses œuvres.
Le miroir montre donc ici autre chose
que ce que le spectateur verra
s'il tourne directement
le regard sur l'œuvre.
Il parle d'ailleurs de métamorphose
plus que d'anamorphose.
Et c'est vrai que c'est assez déroutant.
Et les français sont très bons pour
les sculptures qui font mal au crâne.
Genre Pascal Buclon qui est un autre
artiste français né en 1959.
Lui, travaille sur la profondeur
et sur l'assemblage des structures,
qui une fois indépendantes
ne veulent plus rien dire.
Et c'est en assemblant
des éléments de la structure
que la sculpture prend du sens.
La version ultime de ça,
c'est ce que vous voyez actuellement.
C'est les œuvres de Bernard Pras.
Qui est un artiste
photographe français, toujours !
Né en 1952 en Charente.
La maison !
Lui s'est inspiré
sûrement d'Arcimboldo.
qui au 16ème siècle,
créé des peintures de portraits
en assemblant des fruits, des légumes,
de poissons et des plantes.
Pras, lui, prend plein d'objets différents
pour les assembler dans un grand espace.
Et si on observe depuis
un seul point précis de la pièce,
on voit quelque chose de très précis.
En général des portraits.
Au début de la vidéo,
je vous parlais aussi de ceux qui
sculptent avec l'ombre et la lumière.
Alors il s'agit pas de faire
le chien contre le mur.
ça nous aussi, on sait faire.
Il s'agit de faire comme Shigeo Fukuda,
qui est né en 1932 et décédé en 2009.
Qui était un artiste Japonais plasticien,
dessinateur, illustrateur,
graphiste, sculpteur,
designer d'objets, scénographe.
Et comme par hasard,
c'était un grand admirateur d'Escher
dont on parlait
au début de la vidéo.
Et que vous trouverez
dans le prochain Curiouz,
gros dossier sur lui.
Fukuda crée des ombres à partir
d'un tas d'objets qui ressemble à rien !
Là c'est juste cette ombre
de moto qui est fabriquée
à partir de 848 pièces de coutellerie,
des cuillères, des fourchettes,
des couteaux soudés ensembles
et suspendus dans les airs.
Et dans sa sculpture,
"One cannot cut the sea".
Ces sont 2000 ciseaux soudés,
qui reconstituent un bateau à voile
en ombre portée.
Et un peu comme les figures impossibles
de Francis Tabary,
Fukuda a recréé dans l'espace,
certains des dessins d'Escher
comme le belvédère.
Ou encore la cascade impossible
qui fonctionne réellement avec de l'eau.
Dans la lignée de Fukuda,
je vous laisse quelques images
aussi de Wiegman,
un artiste Néerlandais, qui est
un des pionniers du travail de l'ombre.
C'est magnifique,
on voit Michael Jackson
ou encore Anne Frank dont le visage
flotte au milieu des branchages.
Ou encore le David de Michel-Ange.
Une partie du travail
de Noble et de Webster.
Tous les deux nés
dans les années 60 en Angleterre.
Ah, et dans la même génération
que ces deux là,
il y a aussi Kumi Yamashita,
une artiste japonaise.
Et en 2003, elle a réalisé "city view".
Et là c'est le gros coup de cœur.
C'est une silhouette de femme
accoudée à une rambarde,
qui observe le paysage.
cette silhouette est créée
par une multitude de chiffres
en relief collés au mur.
Et la lumière, elle,
qui rase le mur va créer l'ombre.
Et alors on a la sensation
que la silhouette se désintègre,
alors que ce sont des éléments
eux-mêmes qui la créent.
Donc tout son travail et l'alliance
entre le réel, les vrais matériaux existants.
Et l'immatériel,
les ombres et la lumière.
Et puis après les gars
vont toujours plus loin.
Genre John V. Muntean.
Lui, il crée des sculptures où suivant
de quel côté on met la lumière,
l'ombre va envoyer une sculpture
d'ombres complètement différente.
D'autres sont allés sur
la précision absolue, comme Vaitsis.
Il prend un bric à brac de métal
et hop on fait Einstein,
mais genre hyper précisément.
Ou le Che ou Marilyn ou Loïc.
Larry Kagan dont je rêverais de voir
ses sculptures en vrai un jour,
pour comprendre comment
ce bazar peut être organisé.
Ce sont des enchevêtrements
de fils métalliques
qui sont parfaits
pour créer des ombres.
A partir du moment où la source
de la lumière est placée au bon endroit.
J'arrive pas à comprendre
comment le résultat
peut être aussi propre,
aussi nickel.
Parce que quand
je regarde les photos,
j'ai l'impression qu'il manque
du matériel, de la matière
pour faire cette ombre là pleine.
C'est fou.
Et pour terminer
sur l'ombre et la lumière.
Un travail, je sais pas
où le classer en fait,
de Fred Eerdekens.
C'est un Belge né en 1951,
qui a basé son travail
sur l'assemblage de la matière
des ombres et de la lumière,
pour aller dans l'écriture
au sens propre.
Des mots, des phrases qui sont
au cœur de chacune de ses créations.
D'ailleurs, il avait été choisi
en 2014 par Channel,
pour décorer les vitrines
d'une centaine de leurs boutiques.
les sculptures sont faites avec
des fils de cuivre, qui sans lumière,
ressemblent à un ruban
mais avec des formes gracieuses.
Et une fois qu'on met de la lumière,
et bien il y a une deuxième lecture
qui apparaît.
Je savais pas trop
comment classer cette vidéo.
Et je me suis comme on parle d'Escher,
là quand on a monté le dossier dessus,
c'est la bonne occasion de vous faire
voir tout ça un petit peu en vrac.
C'est ni un top ni un classement,
c'est juste très stimulant de voir aussi
sous quelle forme les œuvres d'art
peuvent s'exprimer.
Et au final, c'est pas parce que
quelque chose n'existe pas
qu'on ne peut pas le faire prendre vie
voire prendre forme dans le monde réel.
Même si à la base,
c'était impossible.
Je trouve que c'est un beau message,
c'est une belle conclusion.
Et encore une fois,
c'est un beau truc
qui retourne le cerveau.
Je vous l'ai dit deux fois dans la vidéo,
mais ça vous l'avez compris.
Donc la saison 2
de Curiouz va arriver.
Là c'est le dernier numéro
qui sort le mois prochain,
le dernier numéro
de cette première année.
Merci d'avoir soutenu ce projet.
Et si vous aviez pas
encore connaissance,
Bah ça c'est mon magazine.
ça fait 52 pages,
ça arrive tous les mois
dans votre boîte aux lettres
où que vous soyez dans le monde.
Sans frais de port,
parce que les frais de port sont inclus.
Il y a la version papier,
il y a la version numérique,
il y a la double version.
Vous avez les infos ici.
Et surtout dans la description,
vous avez le site
où vous pourrez voir
des articles déjà.
Voir ce qui est déjà sorti.
Il y a des articles gratuits à lire.
Bref, abonnez-vous si
vous voulez soutenir mon travail,
en recevant un truc cool !
Un vrai magazine, tous les mois.
N'oubliez pas de liker
cette vidéo si elle vous a plu.
Moi je m'appelle toujours
Fabien Olicard.
Vous pouvez vous abonner
en cliquant ici
et surtout activer la cloche.
On vous le dit tout le temps,
mais faites-le, abonnez-vous.
Il y a une personne sur deux
qui n'est pas abonnée.
Ici, je vous mets deux autres vidéos.
ça c'est une vidéo sur
les illusions d'optique avec Farod.
Et là justement,
c'est le Matière Grise avec Pierre Croce,
où on avait fait de la tenségrité.
Prenez soin de vous,
à très bientôt.
Ciao !